Last week, the Internet was
spinning over this video
from Eater Yang,
showing his inventive method
for eating corn on the cob.
-(drill whirring)
-(laughter)
-Oh.
Right after that,
he had to floss his teeth
-with a belt sander and wipe
his ass with a fire. -(laughter)
This impressive clip, that
I assume someone stumbled upon
after their phone auto-corrected
their search for Asian porn,
uh, influenced several imitators
like this young lady.
Comedians...
-(audience groaning)
-MICUCCI: Oh, no. Oh, no.
I love that you already feel
something is going... sideways,
or maybe it's good.
We don't know.
So the question is,
comedians, will she succeed,
or fail, oh, (bleep),
please, oh, no, please?
-Jake. -I just really,
really want her to fail,
-so I'm gonna say fail.
-HARDWICK: Okay.
Let's find out.
♪
(audience groaning)
BLUMENFELD:
Oh. Whoa.
-(laughter, groaning)
-Oh.
HURWITZ:
I didn't want that to happen.
I didn't want that.
HARDWICK: You said
that's what you wanted.
-I feel like I caused it.
-You did cause it.
-Oh, no. -This is exactly
what you wanted, Jake.
-Oh, no.
-This is what...
You did this to this girl.
(laughter)
This, uh... this video,
by the way,
is at the top of Corn Hub
right now...
under the name
"Hairless Asian Gets Drilled."
-Oh.
-(laughter)
She's probably fine.
(applause and cheering)
She didn't clip off
any brain matter there.
(laughing):
It'll grow back.
MICUCCI:
Oh, man.
Now, don't put a drill
in your face.
I don't know what to say.